today would have been prince philip's
100th birthday
i know there are a lot of people feeling
his absence today
in addition i'd like to point out that
the greet from the british government
has been exemplary
we've had a good first full day here in
the uk
prime minister johnson and i had a very
productive meeting
we discharged and discussed a broad
range of issues
on which the united kingdom and the
united states are working in very close
cooperation
we affirmed the special relationship as
it's not said lightly the special
relationship between our people
and renewed our commitment to defending
the enduring democratic values that both
our nations share
that are strong excuse me the strong
foundation of our partnership
80 years ago prime minister winston
churchill
and president franklin roosevelt signed
an agreement known as the atlantic
charter
it was a statement of first principles a
promise
that the united kingdom and united
states would meet the challenges
of their age and they would meet it
together
today we build on that commitment with a
revitalized atlantic charter
updated to reaffirm that promise while
speaking directly
to the key the key challenges of this
century
cyber security emerging technologies
global health and climate change
we discussed our common goals for
driving ambitious global action to
address the climate
crisis the climate leaders summit that i
hosted in april was in part
about helping drive forward the momentum
toward the critical cop 26
that the uk will host in glasgow later
this year
we talked about the shared sacrifices
our service members have made
bravely serving side by side in
afghanistan
for close to 20 years the uk was with us
from the start as they always are
equally committed
to rooting out the terrorist threat and
now we're coordinating our withdrawal
together
and of course we talked about how our
two nations
can't together lead the global fight
against
covert 19. that's been a major focus of
the g7 under british leadership
particularly in focusing and
coordinating
our resources to help vaccinate the
world
and tonight i'm making an historic
announcement regarding america's
leadership
in the fight against cover 19. america
knows
firsthand the tragedies of this pandemic
we've had we've had more people die in
the united states
than anywhere in the world nearly 600
000 of our fellow americans moms dads
sons daughters brothers sisters
grandparents
more deaths from kova 19 in the united
states
than from world war one world war ii
the vietnam war and 9 11
combined combined
we know the tragedy we also know
the path to recovery the united states
has now vaccinated 64 percent
of our adults with at least one shot
just four and a half months ago we're at
only
five percent with one shot
it took a herculean effort on the part
of our government
to manage one of the biggest and i would
say most complicated logistical
challenges in our history
took the ingenuity of scientists
building on decades of research to
develop a vaccine
it took the full capacity of american
companies
manufacturing and delivering the
vaccines around the clock
and as a result we have the lowest
number of daily deaths since the first
day of this pandemic
our economy is rebounding our
vaccination program has already saved
tens of thousands of lives
with that count growing each day has
allowed
millions millions of americans get back
to living their lives
and from the beginning of my presidency
we've been clear-eyed
that we need to attack this virus
globally as well
this is about our responsibility our
humanitarian obligation
to save as many lives as we can
and our responsibility to our values
we value the inherent dignity of all
people
in times of trouble americans reach out
to offer help and offer a helping hand
that's who we are and when we see people
hurting and suffering anywhere around
the world
we seek to help as best we can that's
one under both republican and democratic
presidents
the united states has made
transformative commitments
to bolster global health commitments
under
president bush like pepfar which changed
the global fight against hiv aids
and in this moment our values called us
to do
everything that we can to vaccinate the
world
against covet 19.
it's also in america's self-interest as
long as the virus rages elsewhere
there's a risk of new mutations that
could threaten our people
we know that raging covet 19 in other
countries
holds back global growth raises
instability
and weakens governments and as we've
seen in the united states
with evidence clear day by day
the key to reopening and growing
economies is to vaccinate your people
our vaccination program has helped the
american economy begin to recover
from the worst economic crisis in a
century
over two million new jobs created just
in the last four months since i've
become president
an historic decline in long-term
unemployment
businesses reopening and a projected
economic growth
of nine point excuse me six point nine
percent
the fastest and nearly four decades in
america
just as the american economy is
recovering
it is in all of our interest to have the
global economy begin to cover recovery
as well
and that won't happen unless we can get
this pandemic under control worldwide
that's why as i said in my address to
the joint session of congress in april
america will be the arsenal of vaccines
in our fight against global 19.
just as america was the arsenal
democracy during world war ii
over the past four months we've taken a
number of steps
toward this historic effort we have
contributed more than any nation to
kovacs
a collective global effort that is
delivering covert 19 vaccines across the
world
we've supported manufacturing efforts
abroad through our partnerships with
japan
india and australia known as the quad
we've shared doses with our neighbors
canada
and mexico and in addition
three weeks ago with america's vaccines
america's vaccine supplied secured and
with confidence we have enough vaccines
to cover
every american who wants one we
announced that we would donate
80 million doses of our own vaccine
in-house now
to supply the world by the end of june
many of these doses are shipping to
countries around the world as we speak
and today we're taking a major step that
will supercharge the global fight
against this pandemic
in my direction the united states will
purchase
an additional half billion doses from
pfizer
pfizer vaccine that will donate nearly
100 low and lower middle-income
countries they will be the beneficiaries
let me say that again the united states
will purchase a half a billion doses
of pfizer covert 19 vaccine to donate to
nearly 100 nations that are in dire need
in the fight against this pandemic
that's a
historic step the largest single
purchase and donation of covet 19
vaccines
by any single country ever importantly
this is the mrna vaccine
which has proven to be extremely
effective
against covet 19 and every known variant
of that virus thus far
these half a billion vaccines will start
to be shipped in august
as quickly as they roll off the
manufacturing line
200 million of these doses will be
delivered
this year 2021 and 300 million more will
be delivered in the first half
of 2022. let me be clear
just as with the 80 million doses we
previously announced
the united states is providing these
half million doses
with no strings attached let me say it
again
with no strings attached
our vaccine donations don't include
pressure for favors or potential consent
concessions we're doing this to save
lives
to end this pandemic that's it period
i also want to thank albert bora
pfizer ceo and chairman for joining me
today
we've gotten to know each other over the
last few months
he and i and his entire team have really
uh
he's really stepped up at this critical
stage in our fight against the pandemic
and the plan is for a half a billion
doses
that we'll be sending around the world
to be produced in the united
states including at pfizer's
manufacturing plant in kalamazoo
michigan
80 years ago not too far from that plant
in kalamazoo
in the detroit area american workers
built tanks and planes
and vehicles that helped defeat the
global threat of fascism in world war ii
they built what became known as the
arsenal of democracy
now a new generation of american men and
women
working with the days of working with
today's latest technology
is going to build a new arsenal to
defeat the current enemy of world peace
health instability kova 19.
albert was gracious enough to welcome me
to kalamazoo plant back in february
it's incredible the ingenuity the care
the safety that goes into every single
dose as i toured the entire plan
most of all when you're there you feel
the pride of every worker there feels
how the pride they feel and what they're
doing
i've been to a lot of plants i've worked
i'm a big union guy i've been doing it
my whole career but you could see the
looks on their faces
they were proud i mean sincerely they
were proud
of what they were doing they knew what
they were doing
american workers will now produce
vaccines to save lives of people in
africa
asia latin america and the caribbean
people they will never meet and have
never met
places they've never visited and
probably won't have an opportunity to
but lives saved all the same thanks to
american leadership
american workers hard work and values
let me close with this this is a
monumental commitment by the american
people
as i said we're a nation full of people
who step up at times of need
to help our fellow human beings both at
home and abroad we're not perfect
but we step up we're not alone in this
endeavor that's the point
i want to make we're going to help lead
the world
out of this pandemic working alongside
our global partners
under the uk chairmanship of the g7
democracies of the world are posed to
deliver as well
this u.s contribution is the foundation
for additional coordinated efforts
to help vaccine the world vaccinate the
world
the british government the prime
minister
has led a strong campaign to get people
vaccinated across the uk
i'm grateful they're making their own
generous donation